foreign
we got a chance to connect I think you
if I'm not mistaken you maybe saw a post
on Twitter that you liked about our some
of our work and Outreach in um in Africa
across Kenya
and Uganda Nairobi and Kampala you I
think you had saw one of the posts and
connected and we reached out and um
you're very generous in your platform to
help us kind of spread the word about
what we're doing with the chess
initiative but basically
um get the chess um is an issue that
really wants to spread the gifts of
Chess um all over the world you think
chess is the greatest game in the world
that has incredible benefits
um and like when I say about the
benefits of Chess it's not only the
educational benefits and the the way
that chess helps you think strategically
and planning and all of that it's also
the opportunity the chest of great game
that connects each of us I'm sure on
this stream itself there's people from
tons of different countries and walks of
life and backgrounds and and Chester
provides us an amazing Community where
we can meet and play and interact with
so many different
um people and just enjoy just humanity
and so the gift of Chess is all about
giving out chess sets to um just to the
world as a gift and allowing those
chesses to create opportunities for
other people I'm glad to be here
supporting gift of Chess uh you know
it's obviously you guys are uh doing
God's work for chefs for sure it's uh
you know all of us Grandmasters we're
just all in it for ourselves and uh you
guys are much more selfless and I'm
really glad that
you're doing what you can to have trust
make a difference in all over the world
and in communities that have not
necessarily been exposed to it as much
as they should have been I'm currently
the Global Outreach director and I
started reaching out fast
in Kenya fast spreading there we've
already received a thousand sets
which we've started Distributing to the
major slums of Nairobi we've reached out
to
three major slums of Nairobi and their
kids are very grateful some of them have
never seen chessboards before and we are
grateful for the gift of just to have
given them this opportunity and so
personally I'd love to thank you guys
for the great work the great works you
do ras the gift of Chase under believing
in humanity to a point of action
yeah so personally I've come to see
what's the gift of chess can do yeah
those are partnership with Justice loans
and um with the visit of impact coaching
Network and the gift of chairs we
implemented
um chess as part of the curriculum of
the school so currently we have
225 kids enrolled and all the 225 kids
are learning chess education a couple
months ago what happened was Russ had
reached out and there was a similar
which I got offered to play in New York
I accepted and okay the event was quite
great it was amazingly organized and I
had a lot I had a lot of fun so I I love
this initiative also that the gift of
Chess is supporting to give out chess
sets to kids around the world we go I'm
expecting I've seen pictures of
McClurkin
you know I I've seen
on a screen what it would look like but
when I got there you know people were
warm I didn't feel unsafe I didn't feel
anything other than
that other than I expected to be doing
good there and I expected to to add
something to the lives of the children
mayor that that wasn't there before and
it would give the chance to all of us
that that opportunity to to to Really uh
just show our appreciation and get the
word out of what we're trying to
accomplish uh through go globally and
right here in America uh so yeah that's
one thing that we have gotten accomplish
this is the first time at one of our
facilities prison that we're able to
play online chess championships so going
forward
it may open up the doors to do it up
more times for most of us here we're in
different parts of the world you know
and um the one thing that brings us all
together and brings this all together is
Trust in a universal language and I mean
I just want to tell people that
um we have a vision to use chess as a
tool right to help create you know an
intellectual identity for some of the
children that live in Muslim communities
right and to us you know in our own
privilege my thing is just a fun game
that we can just play every now and then
and enjoy but to a child you know in the
slums you know living in business
conditions you know it could mean
everything to them and you know the
level of confidence I give them that
they are able to also show intellectual
capacity for something
foreign
[Music]
I think uh I think that went very nicely
I hope uh everyone uh is enjoying
themselves already and thank you for uh
writing in the uh in the in the comments
that the sound was too low it was my bad
I was uh preparing something and then I
left the sound too low but I fixed it
after a few seconds so
uh well all in all uh thanks for that
and uh yeah we are here uh the gift of
Chess arena is starting in 17 minutes
and this is already the second stream we
are enjoying with the gift of Chess um a
community uh here we have rasmakovski he
was with us the last time uh hello Russ
how is everything
thank you uh once again uh for having us
and uh we're super excited looks like
there's nearly
um 1500 players ready to play today so
we're excited for a great day of Chess
yeah yeah uh I'm I'm guessing it's in 15
minutes probably will get close to 2 000
as most of them uh basically decide a
minute before it starts whether they
want to play or not
yeah and this time I think um we spoke
about it we're uh we're gonna add uh a
little fun to the event
um General Stoner put up some prize fun
which always makes us extra fun so I
think uh there's some nice uh prizes out
there
um for the winners and um and hopefully
a lot of people tune in and hear about
all the great work that we are doing but
also play for some uh for some fun for
some fun prizes as well
okay last time we also had some great
prizes uh chess sets uh which is very
nice but as usual more people show up
for for when there's money involved uh
but you know okay
just just entered the tournament uh as
you can see he is uh almost 150 rating
points higher rated than the uh second
player so yeah it's gonna be it's gonna
be fun
very good
uh so what what can we expect from
today's stream from today's guests what
will we learn uh What uh what's changed
since last time we spoke to each other
uh basically you know in in in short
yeah so um last time we met on this on
the stream was nearly a year ago and we
had just landed uh 5 000 chess sets into
Africa they came into Nigeria which was
3 000 sets into Nigeria originally and
then 2000 sets uh landed in Kenya and um
from there the project really
um began to organically unfold
um and you know once people started
seeing what we were doing
um on social media on Twitter we got to
reach out from
um a friend a friend of ours now good
friend of mine named Ronald from Uganda
and he said I see these sets coming out
and he asked for a thousand sets coming
into Kenya so we actually put one of
those thousand sets from from Canyon in
on a truck and it landed into Kampala
Ugandan and that was it once we realized
that we could mobilize chess sets into
countries and that we we really realize
the the uh the demand and the
um the need for chess sets
um we really began to think wow this
could really become a project that can
become not only a project in Africa but
a global project so from from Kenya we
got sets into Uganda and we were in
Kenya and then from Nigeria we got a
thousand sets of nagada so last time we
spoke we were in four countries Ghana
Nigeria Kenya and Uganda and what we
realized is that chess is an incredibly
popular game globally and it has
incredible benefits social benefits the
game of chess
um you're going to hear shortly from
Howard Burton who did a deep dive into
the game of chess in the history but
maybe the greatest game in the history
of the world and the greatest tool for
empowerment is low cost it's played
globally it's got incredible
um
transferable skills it's educational
it's um it's social it's rehabilitative
it's integrative and it's a gameplay
globally and so once we realized that
the game of chess is such a powerful
tool and it's played everywhere what we
were surprised about with the shocking
part was the lack of chess sets globally
do you know there's a lack of chess sets
um globally that in most communities and
in most countries they don't have access
to chess sets it's probably because
there's no domestic manufacturing it's
probably because they're expensive and
it's probably because of a million
reasons but the reality is
most people in this world don't have
access to a physical chess set and even
though chess is the greatest game in the
world and has incredible benefit without
a chest that you can't play and benefit
from the game of chess and the funny
thing is I think that chess is LeapFrog
technology more people are playing on
leeches and chess.com and online then
those that have access to physical
chesses so many people have never
actually played on a physical board are
are big fans and enthusiastic of the
game but you know the reality is you
can't create a chess club in a school
without chess sets you can't create a
chess team you can't go into a prison
and create rehabilitated programs
without chess sets you can't go into
Refugee communities and create chess
programs and opportunities without chess
sets so we realize that our goal really
would become is to bridge the gap with a
tremendous reach that chess has their
tremendous popularity chess has never
been more popular
but also the lack of chess sets globally
and the gift of Chess wants to come in
and um and close that Gap make chess
more available to more people more
globally to use chess as a low-cost
opportunity Catalyst and you're going to
hear a lot about what we do but we're
focused on three major Outreach
initiatives we're trying to use chess's
educational tool you're going to hear
from TuneIn from chess and the slums
after he says let's reimagine chess
Beyond The Four Walls of a classroom
because let's reimagine education Beyond
The Four Walls of a classroom because
true education builds the capacity to
think now what greater game than the
building and capacity I think than chess
and we say don't be distracted by the
plastic peaches pieces the magic of the
game of chesses in the brain synapses
every position
it's something you got to work through
in your mind you got to think a move two
moves three moves ahead you gotta you
gotta use and you got you gotta use
those same tools that you use in a more
in a more sort of traditional
environment if you're solving a math
problem you're involved in Sciences not
everybody access to that but if you can
put kids in thought-provoking moments
where they're solving chess problems and
playing the game with chess that's
education because we're building the
capacity to think you're also going to
hear about our prison outreach program
you know led by Tony Ballard in the
United States that chess is a cognitive
Rehabilitation tool for those
incarcerated to help them change their
life you know we get letters
um aggravator we get letters every day
in the mail because your content is
being streamed all over the prisons in
the United States in over 40 countries
uh 40 States and I think 400 facilities
people are watching your videos you you
were kind enough to lend us your library
of videos they're watching your videos
on on on their platforms they have
tablets in the in the facilities and you
know what they're saying
that you're you're their Lifeline the
chest of their life you're the Escape be
on the four walls of their of their
prison cell they might be in solitary
confinement but when they can get when
they can get lost in a game of chess
their brain goes somewhere else not only
are they learning critical skills that
are going to help them be successful
upon release
you know how to think strategically how
to plan how to work hard towards
something you know really important
skills they also have an escape from the
tough reality that a lot of them
experienced the chess is incredibly
important in the prison so we have the
education led by um kundi and he's been
doing great work he'll be on here Tony
Ballard will be joining us as well
talking about Chess and prisons and we
also have chess in the refugee
communities and we also have um our
director of refugee Outreach he's
actually around a chess program in a
refugee resettlement camp in Uganda it's
called the raised chess Academy his name
is Josh Julian and he was a refugee
himself but he started a chess Academy
and what better way to help integrate
people that are that are new to a new
country or a new community that don't
have any sort of home base to connect
them through a shared game like the game
of chess you don't need to speak the
same language you don't need to know
anything but you sit across that board
you're going to create human
interactions you're going to integrate
these kids and you're going to give
these kids opportunities
um very powerful opportunities so to get
the chance of getting chestnuts out
globally we hope to reach 1 million
chess that's distributed by 2030 and
we're doing it by Distributing 1 000
chess sets each country globally
um right now we have 50 000 chess sets
in Africa we've um we've already reached
12 countries in Africa with a thousand
chess sets each and today the stream
really is about helping mobilize the
chess Community the resources needed to
get the additional 50 000 chess out sets
out to every country in Africa
we have countries lining up they want
the chess sets we have contacts we have
the ability to get it done we just need
help with the resources to make it
possible we're asking five thousand
dollars per country will allow us to
mobilize the chess sets that are already
there they're already paid for they're
sitting in a warehouse in Ghana they're
sitting in a warehouse in Kenya and we
need the resources to mobilize them put
them on plane train automobile pay for
the costumes and once they land these
countries we need a budget to help
distribute
um we're doing micro distribution which
is five chess set gifts so we get a
thousand chested they break them into
five that reaches 200 institutions in a
country now when you hear from South
Sudan when we gave them a thousand chess
sets into South Sudan you know they're
in the middle of a tremendous challenges
in their country we ran we lend a
thousand chestnuts into Juba and he said
the chest is the gift of Chess provided
was more chess sets than they had in the
entire country
they're going after schools orphanages
prisons so that's where the gift of
Chess is today's All About Us building
upon what we've done like I said we're
in 12 countries and you're going to hear
from the ambassadors from each of these
countries but countries um you know now
we're in Ghana uh Uganda Kenya um
Nigeria South Sudan or in Somalia
Tanzania
um Zambia Malawi Zimbabwe
um Seychelles just to name a few and
we're going to reach all of Africa
um they love chess chess is exploding on
on Africa they don't have chess sets and
we're going to change that we're going
to get in the resource that they can
start Grassroots programs using the game
of chess as a low-cost tool to provide
change in the communities and we're
going to get it done and I want to thank
you once again for your generous uh
generosity letting your platform we're a
big fan of yours we uh we consider you
the greatest greatest person in the
Chess World and not because of your
content but for your heart and passion
your willingness to come alongside of us
and give us the opportunity to speak
today to a global audience so thank you
um hopefully that was a brief update
I'll I'll be introducing our team
throughout the day but I think uh
hopefully that was um a good overview
and I'll hand it back to you
uh all right uh I'm also uh very
grateful to be a small part of your team
uh you know you guys are basically doing
all the work I'm I'm really informing
people of uh of your success uh so uh
I'm very very glad to be a this small
part but yeah uh how many guests will be
uh hearing from today
so we're gonna have a an ambassador from
each country so each country we land we
have we have an ambassador that's it's
they're responsible for the distribution
of their country so each country's
Ambassador will speak to you about what
chess looks like in different countries
um from you know from across Africa and
the United States and then we'll have a
couple of key guests we'll have um
abhiman yamish or the youngest Grand
Master history will come by and say
hello Tony Ballard who's the director of
prison Outreach will be on to say a lot
we have on the young eight-year-old
chess champion from Abuja Nigeria uh
Evie she was just featured today on the
BBC and recently Reuters and she's going
to talk about her experience we have
Bernice wambui out of Kenya she was the
u18 chess champion in Kenya um and she's
only 12 and she's an incredible uh
player and also she's an ambassador for
the get to chess
um Tyrone Davis from the United States
one of our founding board members he'll
be saying a couple words um we actually
have our our recently appointed Global
head of the gifted chess which I'll be
introducing
um shortly so yeah I think we're gonna
have an action-packed list of guests and
I hopefully you'll find find their
stories interesting and compelling but
also I think that you'll find this story
similar I think that's the beauty of the
game of chess is the similarities of
what we share is really the power and
the strength of the game so and some of
them are also playing in the tournament
so they're going to be multitasking
yeah we had a joke to see what country
from our gift to chess is going to be
the most well represented and I was
wondering what country was going to win
the most top 25 finishes and I heard
Nigeria was pretty confident about this
Nigeria playing but we have a lot of
people from different countries in the
world so I think at the end of the
tournament I'm going to take a look at
what country finished the most players
in the top 25 and we'll do something
special maybe we'll sing their national
anthem on the next uh on the next stream
in the next in years to come
yeah uh that will inspire others to also
strive for that
so um
can I um
I started I can introduce um our first
guest unless you um there's anything
else that we need to take note
uh no basically the tournament is
starting in five minutes so the
tournament will be running in the
background we're going to be focusing on
the guests uh the tournament is merely
uh you know uh
uh usually whenever whenever I have
something on the channel there's always
a tournament in the background so it's
now going to be uh weird to for anyone
yeah it looks like we have
almost 1700 players
and uh I think we're five minutes out I
wouldn't be surprised if it climbs from
there but what a what an amazing
um group and a lot of strong players
um as well so I'm excited I invited a
lot of our coaches from New York City
and at first when I was talking I said
hey we're going to go out there and
represent and we were all the top
players until about 24 hours ago they
all been bumped out of the top out of
the top ten just shows the strength of
this uh International uh event and I
want to call it this it's it's the it's
the charity stream of the summer you
know and hopefully it won't only be a
great chess tour I really hope that
people listening will hear what we're
doing and will be motivated and inspired
to come alongside of us this project is
so large it's so important it's
impacting so many lives it's having
generational impact that someone that
hears this will say hey how can I help
how can I help and there's a million
ways to help but it's the today's about
a call to action we've we've moved
Heaven and Earth we've given everything
that we've had to this project every
every every bit of what each of us can
offer and we brought it so far and to
keep moving forward we need more and
more people to to come alongside us and
be part of this gift of Chess
um it's a global project and it
represents all of us all of us this is
the people's project and it's for the
People by the people and this and
today's a call to action so
all right there we go
uh all right three minutes uh three
minutes until we start uh it's pretty
much yeah when I joined the tournament I
was of course uh uh the leading the the
tournament uh but then maybe a couple of
hours before the tournament now I'm
number 100 I think I can let me just
check if I joined now
uh I can't even join oh no I'm 278 yeah
very nice and also I was gonna say I I
think I should
um is a custom boards that have your um
have your YouTube channel on it they get
to chest we'll be giving those out today
in support of uh of generous donors
um I think anybody that makes a donation
um over 250 dollars towards a campaign
will be happy to get a a board out I
think you have a photograph of it if not
I posted on our Twitter account but it's
a beautiful custom board
um that um was given to us for this
event and hopefully that'll be a nice
nice little extra um incentive you want
to find out where the boards it's it's
called Brio boards.com they saw us
online and like I said coming alongside
us they said hey we love what you're
doing can we donate custom boards for
this event and we said surely and so we
appreciate them so we'll share those but
we'll be giving those out for
um to recognize those that have been
generous with the donations um today as
well
oh that is very nice
very nice possible to do great things
from a small place I I just love that
sentence
yeah
and you know um tundi who who who coined
that phrase yeah I don't know if you've
been following but he recently had some
medical issues where he had surgery uh
oh no I I did not hear that yeah but
he's recovered and uh he's out of the
hospital and he's um he's back on his
feet if you can see he posted a Twitter
update but he's learning how to walk
again he had to have a full um hip
replacement I believe he'll be on later
but he coined the phrase and you know he
inspired I would say me in many ways to
really come alongside of him and build
upon the work that he did but he said
it's possible to great things from a
small place when I saw him under the
bridge in a showdy you know
and the world was celebrating him and he
was saying it's possible to great things
from a small place it really blew my
mind and if you look I don't know if you
can see the back of my shirt
get the chest shirt but
ah yeah there it is there it is
there it is we put it on the back of all
of our shirts because that's how we
believe you know it's possibly great
things from a small place so yeah I
actually tries to order the Fila the the
the their hat but they don't I can't do
it from Croatia for some reason uh yeah
I I was I was lucky enough Tyrone Davis
who's here
um from New York from LaGuardia to Legos
uh International Airport with 500 chess
sets and I gave Tony a Yankee hat and uh
so I gave him because I was this is like
my chest feel as New York the New York
Yankee and I always wear that and I gave
him a Yankee hat in exchange for a chess
field so Tyrone came back with one of
the chess feelers and I took a pillow
pitches wearing the Nigerian hat when I
was at Tyrone so that was that was good
fun you know
all right so uh we've officially started
uh there we go
uh let me just check if the games have
started yes they have
and there we go
Chicago Sergey versus Vladimir which
first game uh let's uh check it out let
me just uh
let me just fix the
there we go
sorry about that
all right I don't want the delicious
sounds to be too loud I think this will
be this will be okay if they're too loud
just mention it in the comments I'm just
gonna uh fix that let me just maybe we
could do it even more a little bit there
we go
foreign
so I'm going to be tending to the
tournament and you are welcome to to
introduce our first guest who will be
who will be talking to everyone okay
very well so
um thank you everybody for joining um
it's gonna be a great day
um charity chess tournament and uh
stream in support of the get to chess
thank you um aggravated for being a
gracious host um today I'm going to
introduce many of our Global team people
that represent our ambassadors in
different countries and
um have supported our project along the
way
um the first guest I'd like to
um introduce is a recently announced
Global head of the gift of chess for
several years we were really looking for
someone to take our project
um to the next level give a strong
leadership and a strong voice someone
that we can rally behind and several
months ago we connected with uh Susan
namangali from Malawi
um she learned chess playing as a young
child I think she was gifted a chess set
by the Peace Corps and with that single
single chess set it created incredible
educational opportunities for herself
she went on to get a great education and
um and at some point obviously through
her Evolution she was um what are the
the first ever uh president uh female
president of African Chess Federation
um and she wanted to travel the world
into really inspire a lot of people in
her role as the African first female
president from Malawi we connected and
her experience 30 years being in the
chess Community being around being
around leadership and just being a true
story of the impact of Chess we asked
her to
um
help lead us to our our goal of reaching
one million chestnuts by 2030 and she's
she's recently joined but she's already
hit the ground running and I speak to
her on a daily basis and I'm couldn't be
more excited for half her to help lead
our project so I'll invite her to um
kick off the event and say a couple
words so Susan
um welcome and um
floor is yours
great
um welcome Susan
thank you good morning good afternoon uh
everyone
uh so I'm super excited I'm super
excited to join this stream
um I must say that this is my first time
to join you know um um such such a short
stream and I'm super excited with the
you know the turnouts that we have for
this tournament uh well done everyone
that has joined uh I must say that you
know I'm we're very happy you know to
have everyone supporting you know what
we're doing as you know that we have a
goal of Distributing 1 million tested
globally and right now as Ross
introduced we've made strides uh we have
already reached you know 13 countries in
Africa and we are expanding uh very fast
and so we really need support and so far
we're grateful for all the support that
we we we're getting from you know from
everyone and you know the reason why we
also hosting I mean hosting this event
this tournament is because we need
support and so I'm so excited that we
have you know over 1 000 you know
players from all over the world joining
and and being part of this event
I I must say that you know I come from
Malawi as as RAF said and in Malawi as
well uh we we come along with the warm
heart of Africa and you know with the
lack of Chase sets you know and with uh
with the gift of Chess we have managed
to in you know introduce chess even
today I had to reach areas of our of our
country uh in Malawi and I know that in
many countries where we are reaching out
with the chess set we have beautiful and
exciting stories that are you know that
are coming up you know um uh from our
distribution or from our Outreach so
thank you very much thank you I've met
her for you know hosting us for hosting
you know this stream and thank you
everyone for joining uh for joining our
event please keep sharing you know at
the University language of Chess keep
being part of the event
um we'll be reaching out you know to as
many countries and we hope to even meet
some of you um in the near future thank
you very much
okay thank you Susan
um so
um again we have a special guest he's a
agree to join I think he's in the middle
of a tournament but he's uh coming off a
real great run he just finished the U.S
junior Chess Championship and won clear
first place I think the US junior is a
top tournament in the United States for
players under 20 and he's only 14.
um I believe he's the top player in the
world under 16 if that's if I'm correct
youngest Grand Master in the history of
Chess and I think his next goal is to
break 2600 the youngest ever but uh
Grandmaster avimanyu is here and I'd
like to give him a couple of minutes to
um to say hello and to share some words
of encouragement for the uh get their
chest hi everyone it's great to be here
how is everything
yeah things are going fine how about you
uh great as usual I have the the
privilege of Hosting this great event I
hope we we reach a lot of people and
maybe maybe even uh acquire some sets
for a country or two would be nice
definitely how was how was the
tournament for you you just finished
your your junior Championship
yeah Juniors was
I won the tournament I got clear first
but it definitely wasn't my best
tournament like I got six out of nine
but I feel like men in many of the in a
couple of games I wasn't playing to my
potential and I was like I was lost in
two of the games oh okay I I I actually
thought it uh uh you know you were maybe
afraid that it wouldn't even be a
challenge for you
uh since uh last time we we've spoken
that you said that uh definitely your
goal was to become the youngest world
champion ever is that still the goal
yes hopefully still the goal how much
how much time do you still have I mean
uh what's what's the youngest in months
youngest world champion I'm not entirely
sure but yeah the next
I still have around like four or five
years I guess oh okay so yeah two is
plenty like in three you could probably
do it easily
I'll try I'll try yeah so uh what What's
your rating currently
like 25 90 around there okay so closing
in on 2600.
yes what's the next event for you yeah
so now I'm playing in the the summer
chest classic uh things haven't been
going so well as of now but I'm hoping
to bounce back
and uh do you already have some plans
for for the year or yeah after this I'll
be after this I'll be going to Spain for
a Spanish league and after that a U.S
Championship is the next or the next
couple tournaments
okay so do you feel do you feel that
you're already do you have the strength
to be a 2600 player and it's merely a
matter of time you know once you play
some games definitely definitely
do what do you feel you still have to
conquer to be able to let's say become a
2700 player
it mainly suffer from consistency issues
some days I play amazing some days I
play terribly
uh where does it usually go wrong in in
the opening or or you know finding a
game plan or like like throughout the
whole game like some days I'll see like
I'll be able to calculate like a lot
more than usual and some days okay I
just I'm not able to see anything moves
I would usually play in like five
seconds after spending 10 minutes I
won't play the same move and uh are you
are you working alone or do you have a
coach
I have I have coaches coaches and how do
you how does one train to overcome lack
of consistency
well I guess the main thing is that you
just keep you have to always remain
Sharp
always be ready with with your openings
with your tactics with just about
everything
and solve like 100 heavy problems every
day yes
well okay 100 is
a lot debatable but yeah now
um I know you have to run but before you
do run do you have any words of
encouragement for the gift of chest or
maybe
um anything you want to share in uh
encourage other people to get behind
what we are doing as a as a top player
that really I think believes in the game
of chess with the power
um any any words before you you head out
sure the gift of Chess is an amazing
movement I'm honored to be associated
with them I mean spreading chess All
Around the World in such fashion is
incredible
one one advice I would give young
players is that as long as you work hard
and you plan everything and you execute
it well or anything is possible
thank you
thank you thank you I'll remind you very
well put
um thank you avimanyu is um who
represents the uh get to chess
um when he plays and travels I think he
encourages people to learn more about
what we're doing and um support us and
we need visible people and and and and
leaders in the chess Community to really
uh lend their platform voice and
abhimani has done just that and he's
been in a an incredible success um even
just in the last several years of
working with him um his hard work and
his consistency and his commitment to
the game and to Excellence into our
program has been um has been amazing so
thank you Avi and thank you for joining
and um Good Luck
um in all of your events thank you
um so we have another special guest
um it's a friend that I think in in some
ways he we were both highlighted through
his work and he he did an incredible
um amount of work and research and deep
dive into the chess community in the
historical context and just
um really incredible
um work um in in some senses in in an
academic sense um Howard Burton who's um
a filmmaker amongst other things
um he recently published
um a book called chess essays that I
encourage you guys all to check out and
also a four-part documentary series
um that is called through the mirror of
Chess a cultural exploration I asked him
to come because through all this
research I don't know if he came from as
the angle of being a chess player but
he's certainly probably knows more about
Chess than most of us on this stream
after his Deep dive into the Chess World
so I I invite him to come and just share
I think um his thoughts on the get the
chess project and the importance of
Chess as an Outreach tool so thanks for
joining Howard well it's my pleasure
thanks very much for having me and uh
hello to everyone hello to uh to you
Russ who I've come to know quite well
through the last little while and also
Akinator I think uh who does fantastic
job and and leech us as well as a
platform they also do a great job and
they were you know they were also
involved in uh as you said the research
that I did so uh uh Michelle I just
blather on or do you want to do you want
to ask me something more specific or do
you want me to just yeah well I know
that you published a piece on on uh on
chess.com about the importance and the
reasons why chess is such a great tool
for empowerment globally so maybe just a
quick recap on your on your on your
experience on why why the Gita chess is
an important Outreach and maybe
encourage people to really it's not just
chess it's a humanitarian effort and if
you care about education if you care
about refugees and Rehabilitation
opportunities and you care about prison
reform then support the kids of Chess um
and that you know maybe give us a little
bit of a background on that sure so I'll
give you a background on how I got
involved in this project and I'll
culminate with uh with the the
remarkable transformative social
empowerment opportunities that are
associated with chess which frankly
floored me and took me completely by
surprise and and in particular what you
guys are doing at the gift of Chess and
there's a reason why you played such a
strong role in the film and and also in
the book uh because we don't know each
other I've never never met you before
this while we know each other now but I
didn't meet you before this this whole
project and what I was interested in
doing why I was interested in doing a a
large project on chess wasn't so much
because
I was the biggest fan of Chess or the
most uh fanatical chess player I've
played chess my whole life it was
something that I've always been
captivated by and that I thought was
particularly special but the reason I
was interested in
um in doing this project was because
chess is something that has an enormous
cultural impact and not just a cultural
impact today across different parts of
the world but over time for 1500 years
it's had remarkable not not just as a
game being played but also culturally
it's manifested itself in everything
from political allegories to romance to
Linguistics to artificial intelligence
to computers and I thought
what a really cool project to trace that
not just trace the history of the game
which I think a lot of chess players are
reasonably familiar with but also Chase
its impact Chase its influence in
different societies Chase uh really put
into perspective what it actually has
done in terms of not just the game
itself but how it's impacted hearts and
minds and thoughts and it turns out that
story is just unbelievably fascinating
and much deeper than I had imagined so
as I built this project out I had first
thought more about doing it historically
but what I did is I bookended it so the
first part is not really historical it
just talks about Chess and and societal
stereotypes and and misunderstandings
about that and it features you know a
lot of the stuff that Hollywood gets
wrong that every chess player knows
about and why it has these stereotypes
that don't actually really uh uh really
bear out and also what it what it does
do what it is significant for it and I
think some of these ideas including the
variability of the game is something
that people don't appreciate then I
talked about the history uh in the in
the second and third part and and all of
these things that is far too numerous to
mention but it's really remarkable in
terms of diversity and impact in a wide
variety of cultures not just Western
European culture and not just from a
specific time really it goes it's really
at a global level and then the last film
is all about contemporary impact and
it's divided into two areas it's divided
into how we can get a sense of current
cultural norms and current beliefs and
current attitudes and values through
chess
that's the first half and then the
second half is all about well what are
are there any chess programs are is
chess actually being used very
concretely and very practically in a way
that has a cultural resonance today and
it turns out there are two things that
really stand out and the first is again
I don't have to tell anybody listening
to this stream
um that chess is hugely popular and has
made the transition to an enormous uh
Global part of the sports and
entertainment complex and again we're
sitting on the stream with people who
are contributing to that and it is just
enormously popular and enormously
popular for a reason because of the game
itself because of its intricacy because
of the fact that with a lot of hard work
and effort anybody can actually become
reasonably competent and many people can
really become great it's a it's a
wonderful leveler in terms of ability to
to achieve the highest possible levels
and that's melded so well with
technology in the internet and so forth
and so on is again and videos that and
YouTube that we don't have to dwell on
here but everybody is familiar with so
that's one aspect that's really really
interesting and that makes it play such
a strong role but the other is in terms
of its social impact direct social
impact in terms of Education in terms of
prisons and in terms of social
empowerment these are things that I
highlighted in the film because they
really stood out
I had a little idea about some of the
things that might be able to be done uh
or that might be being done in the Chess
World or in the world through chess but
I had no idea of the extent of it and it
turns out the extent is remarkable I
mean I can't think of something which is
being used as a way of of empowering
people as a way of giving people Pride
as a way of being able to enable them to
develop as a way of enabling them to
have confidence it is the leveler that
really I mean everybody in the world
should pay attention to this independent
of whether or not you're a chess player
this is an opportunity for people
anywhere in the world to be able to not
only Master a game it's much more than
that it's the ability to develop
confidence the the ability to be able to
compete the the the opportunity to be
able to engage in something intellectual
all high level and give themselves the
necessary motivation to be able to not
only Excel at chess but also excel at
life I know this sounds a bit like a
cliche but it's it's really true and
what you guys are doing is just
phenomenally important because I think
one of the things that's a dirty little
secret that everybody knows is that
people in
um in impoverished communities and that
certainly includes
some people in Africa But it includes
people in uh in throughout the world it
includes people in Asia it includes
people in the United States and includes
people all over the place and one of the
things that's that's a a a really
inhibiting factor for them is the sense
that well the game is rigged you know I
can't compete I can't Elevate myself I
can't I'm I'm I don't have any money I
don't have any opportunity I don't have
a a sense because I've been born in the
wrong place the wrong time under the
wrong circumstances there's no way for
me to be able to be successful in the
world and the wonderful thing about
Chess is that that's so manifestly
untrue
that if you have the opportunity to
become familiar with this game you have
the opportunity to be able to get the
resources through things like lead chest
you don't have to pay any money you just
need to have an internet connection now
and you can work hard and you can get
better and you can start having belief
in yourself that all of a sudden There's
an opportunity for you to partake in a
in a in a Level Playing Field and for
many of these people it's the first time
they've had this opportunity to do that
so it not only transforms them in terms
of their
um there are opportunities to be great
chess players it transforms them in the
opportunity to be completely successful
at whatever it is that they choose to do
in life and so I can't think of anything
that's actually more significant and as
you said it costs basically nothing I
mean the amounts of money that we're
talking about for you to be able to do
it costs something for you and your
budget it costs something for all the
players here if they want to donate some
money obviously I'm not trivializing
that but on the overall scheme of things
when you compare it to my God
international Aid budgets I mean it's
it's a joke the the impact that is being
made through chess is the most cost
efficient thing that you can possibly
imagine there is nothing more cost
efficient than that there is nothing
more significant than that and there is
nothing that's more feasible than that
so you know I I'm I'm just so impressed
by the potential that's involved here
this is something that can be done it
should be done and you know God willing
it will be done if enough people can
draw attention to this as you were doing
and the the power of what it is that
you're doing is just formidable and I
think that sooner or later people are
going to really start paying attention
on a global scale you should be you know
you should be a hero man I mean you
should be you should be on the Time
magazine's Man of the Year and uh and
then things will change so hopefully
this will start start the ball rolling
that was that was beautiful
thank you Howard I I you know I I that's
why I asked you to come and speak you've
been around a lot of projects and you've
done a lot of research and you I think
your independent conclusion was the
power of Chess that we've all come to
know is low cost it's transformative it
it it it it it it there's no good reason
why not to do it because of all the
money that we spend on so many different
types of projects globally now I know
people are saying it's not food but you
know you give someone the capacity to
think that's powerful and they can think
for a lifetime you give someone an
intellectual identity give someone
confidence and pride you connect them to
a network those are important food's
important clothing's important housing
is important but there's no reason not
to do Chess at scale it's low cost and
it can provide a tremendous amount of
tools that will lead it's a gateway to
prosperity and I think we've seen that a
million times in the stories that we
tell in the lives of our own lives we've
all experienced that so thank you Howard
I encourage people to um check out your
book in your movie I found it completely
compelling and um just from a just from
an enjoyment perspective I thoroughly
enjoyed I also wanted to tell you before
we move on is that your your your
content your four-part documentary
series is being enjoyed by those
incarcerated across the United States I
think you probably are aware of that but
we're getting feedback that they're
completely um intrigued and compelled
and inspired by the work that you are
doing and you're you're having a great
impact on so many lives and the work
that you do is really meaningful so
thank you so much well it's it's my
pleasure thank you if I have impact in
that way it's certainly uh due to you
maybe I can just say two two more things
before I go about the prison thing one
of the things that I wrote about uh and
you know is that not only is chess I
think really important for prisoners uh
in terms of their opportunity to to
develop skills and to be thinking and so
forth and I had the Good Fortune to be
able to talk to people like you uh talk
to people like Tom Dart talk to people
um
like Carl Portman and so forth they were
doing wonderful work in in chess and
prisons but I think one of the great
things about Chess and prisons is for
people who aren't in prison it makes
them think what are we actually trying
to do in prison anyway is it working is
is it so it's a really important social
issue this isn't of course to do
strictly with chess but it's a wonderful
starting point to get people to start
thinking well what should we be doing
what what is really the point of prison
is it working is it not working how is
it that we are trying to rehabilitate
people can we rehabilitate people can we
Inspire them what should we be doing and
Tom Dart said it very well when he
talked about uh Cook County Jail which
is uh the the prison that he runs he
said Justin chess and prisons is a thing
that's been going on you know for years
and years in some form or fashion all
over the place but most of the time it's
just killing time most of the time they
just throw it out there because they
just want people to you know not kill
themselves or whatever it is there's no
effort made whatsoever to actually try
to engage with people and what he was
doing was trying to do exactly that and
other people have taken up that that
ball and I think it really has
transformative social impact the other
thing I just want to say is
just to reiterate to people something
that you've said many times uh when you
but just when you said now it's not food
okay it's not food but it's not supposed
to be food and and today on okoya I
think said it really well when he said
um and I had the Good Fortune to meet
him through this project as well that
chassis gives people an identity it
enables them to have belief in
themselves it gives them something that
they didn't have before and if you just
go somewhere and you just give people a
handout or you give them a little bit of
food or something I'm not denigrating
obviously people who are doing that sort
of thing but it's not sustainable
because what you have to do in order to
really address social change you have to
give the people who are suffering the
belief that they can oh and the belief
and the and the opportunity to be able
to overcome that situation that they're
in you have to give them you have to
empower them or you have to lead them to
a situation where they can Empower
themselves and if you just throw stuff
at them however you know well-meaning
that is and of course in many cases it
is extremely well-meaning but that's not
going to lead to systematic change the
way you get to systematic change is to
empower those people and one of the
things that I have found through my
research and and through meeting people
such as yourself is that chess is a
magnificent almost independently
magnificent way of empowering those
people so that they can change their own
lives and that's so important and I
think that people really have to
identify with that recognize that and
enable you to be able to achieve your
goal of doing that I don't know how you
have time to actually run a business
which you also do on the side but um but
I I think that's something that should
be recognized and I think people here
should really support it so anybody
listening to this should really dig down
and say you know what I have five or ten
dollars or whatever it is to be able to
enable this to happen because if
everybody does that then you can really
have transformative social change
through chess thanks Howard and like
Howard said if you're listening we have
50 000 chess sets in uh in Africa we've
mobilized across multiple countries but
we need we're calling you to help
support us we need resource to move
these chesses from our distribution
centers and Anna and in Canada to get
them into the hands of the countries
we're going to reach all of Africa but
we need the resource and your support
and it's an incredible powerful tool I'm
going to Pivot I'm going to start
introducing some people from our team in
Africa that are going to tell you some
of the work that's being done and
encourage you to come alongside us and
support
um the first person he just joined um
he's from a refugee camp in Uganda he
founded the raised chess Academy his
name is melee Julian he's a refugee
himself and he's founded to be his
life's work to give that to other
refugees in this community and I'm going
to ask him if he's available if he can
unmute and um
say a couple worlds uh
Joshua are you here
good yes all right I'm here
um hello everyone
uh thank you so much for taking the time
to join this um live stream and um
really honored to be speaking to you all
um my name is my leg Julian Josh and I
am the founder of financials Academy
a community that uh supporting Children
of the children here in aquibilities
settlement in Uganda we are really
blessed to be working together with the
gift of Chess which has been able to
support our Refugee Community here and
also globally
um yes all of you you are
really supporting those marginalized
Refugee children and those with um who
are not being people who have lost their
hopes before with all your support we
are able to regain
um I'm a refugee myself and um being
here being part of this team that is
because of what chess is all is all
about and what opportunity is all about
to give me before I started race chess
Academy I was testing a lot of
challenges together with my family We
Lost Our Father which was a
a moment of depression and the moment
which we wouldn't want any child to face
but because of Chess we were able to
grow to pass through it and right now
I'm able to extend that uh benefit that
I got from chess to others and of course
with all of you we are able to to
achieve and reach where we need to be
thank you so much and I'm looking
forward to speak to you again in other
live shows thank you
thank you
do you want to give any updates on the
competition any any uh anything
interesting going on uh okay uh we've
just finished this game a Grand Master
Pro move uh from planet Earth he does
not have a country let me just check who
that is uh Vladimir zakartov uh has just
won a very nice game and okay let's
check out the standings now so uh
leading the tournament even though there
are many Grand Masters playing is
actually fide master from Armenia Rob uh
I do not know this nickname uh Robert
piliposian
so he's just destroying everyone and now
he lost the game after maybe winning 10
and 10 in a row then we have an unrated
gentleman who is in second place which
is absolutely incredible
uh currently facing off against penguin
uh then we have uh the penguin in number
three that's Andrew tank of course then
Harsha baratakoti we've shown a game he
played uh I think it was two days ago in
in the video World Cup uh then we have
blue car also unrated a very best player
also on rated uh very very interesting
turn of events so many unrated players
in the top 10
also from Armenia then we have Alex
Sakaya and also from Armenia to nartank
Azerbaijan but also unrated and Splendid
kid from India but yeah we are well over
2 000 players we are at 2500 players so
uh very pretty incredible stuff now
could you give us an update on the um on
the charity side have we um how are we
doing on the fundraiser let me just
check if if my software is updating it
uh we are currently uh we have just
crossed 10 of our goal we are currently
at 1200 out of the ten thousand so if
anyone uh if anyone likes the initiative
if if anyone you know uh loves what
we've just heard and I was I was very
impressed uh I mean
uh you're more than welcome to to
contribute and uh let's uh let's try and
reach the goal and let's try and make
this happen so 10 000 will reach two
countries yeah
yeah so I'm gonna call my next guest um
we have two countries that are lined up
that have been waiting um one is I
believe Rwanda in South Africa they're
coming out of Kenya under the uh
leadership of uh Phyllis and uh Phyllis
on the call so I'm gonna give her a
chance to say a couple words and then
phyllis's daughter
um Bernice will also have a chance a
couple words so if if Phyllis or
orbanese are here you guys
um you can you can join us share some
updates what's coming out of Kenya
hello
hi Phyllis hello how are you
I am I am doing well how's Bernice
enjoying the tournament yeah she's
playing
good good so maybe just um we're raising
money obviously to distribute to
additional countries maybe you want to
share with the countries that we've
already distributed from out of Nairobi
and what countries that we are prepared
to ship to once you know hopefully after
this stream we could
um have some resources to mobilize the
next uh several countries
okay so far we've done
uh Nigeria Ghana
Malawi was the first batch for this
2023 we have South Sudan
seashells
Somalia
Uganda
Tanzania
Zambia and Zimbabwe
uh in lineup we have
uh Botswana waiting
uh Ethiopia
South Africa
Congo
DeSoto and eswatini in the way to
wonderful
um
now
you want to just share a little bit of
the process of what it looks like to
ship from
our distribution in Kenya to these
countries give give people a little
understanding of what it looks like to
um logistically to get these sets to the
countries
okay together chess sets uh get to a
country of course we have to get them
from the warehouse from the storage that
we they are in currently after shipping
from the main manufacturer
so
the
we normally pack them in thousands to
get them to the
main distributor which who is in Nairobi
most trip the storage is not so far away
from Nairobi and
the logistics
uh fast we have to check uh
mostly whether it's a country is
accessible by road if not we work on the
logistics by air and after that we make
arrangement to send to our country so we
take them to the airport
They are packed and they pass through
the customs
to now
be delivered to the country of
of this patch
so the logistics range from
uh
close to two thousand dollars
to get to a country by air
and close to around fifteen hundred
dollar by roads
yes
and then show us a little bit about some
of these countries that there's not only
the transportation but there's the
custom duties on receipt correct
yes yes once uh for export once they
leave kenyamos to their nor Duty spot on
adding to any country they are subjected
to
customs and
it's uh it ranges from different
countries they have different policies
for anything coming in so it has been
waging between a thousand to two
thousand depending on the country and
their custom policies
for their thousand choices
well um so thank you so much for your
efforts you've uh they've nicknamed you
The Iron Lady of uh of Africa and um
you've really been the lead on making
sure chestnuts are getting into
communities from the very beginning so
um we thank you now
um Agave if you do have a chance I sent
you a link showing some of the
distribution yeah yeah and we are we are
ready to go can we show that yeah okay
all right there we go
Chase is a game that has been played for
centuries and is enjoyed by people all
over the world
however
that everybody has access to the
equipment needed to play the game
we're excited to announce that we've
received 25
000 chest sites to distribute in
different countries around Africa
through the generosity of the gift of
Chess we are able to spread the wings of
Chess and provide children with the
opportunity to emerge
our goal is to make chess accessible to
everyone
regardless of their background or
economic situation
we are working with local organization
Children's Home willing individuals and
schools to identify areas where we can
grow the Love of the Game and become the
grand Soldier to teach
see firsthand the positive impact the
chess can have on people's lives
it's a game that teaches patience
discipline and perseverance
it's also a great way to meet new people
and make friends we're excited to be
able to provide less privileged
communities opportunities to learn and
play chess
that everyone should have the chance to
experience the benefits of playing chess
join us in our mission to spread the
wings of Chess in Africa
together we can make a difference in the
lives of children everywhere
yeah really puts it into perspective
someone someone has to do all the work
I said we have 20 000 sets have also
arrived in
in Ghana and are being prepared for
distribution across West Africa so I'd
like to ask Charles from Ghana to share
some updates and talk to us about some
of the work that's happening in Ghana so
Charles if you're here
um you can come say hello
hire us
hello everyone
hello Charles
yes good
to connect to all of you
we are so excited here to have received
20 000 chess sets to be donated to what
the western region
uh as I speak now they would declare it
hopefully by Wednesday and will start
dispatching
we have already received a thousand
chess sets for Ghana and it was
distributed
across 16 regions
and we are all so happy because there
are lots of places without chess sets
and this is a treasure for all of us now
it's not going to be only Ghana but it's
going to be Benin it's going to be
Burkina for so Cape Verde Cote d'Ivoire
Gambia Guinea bissau
um Liberia Malawi Mauritania Niger
and we hope that will be peace in
Nigeria soon Nigeria
Senegal Sierra Leone Togo all these
countries are expecting
to receive yeah Thousand Steps
um it does cost a lot in terms of
logistics to distribute and so we are
adding our voices to all well good and
well-meaning people across the globe to
help make this a reality and share the
burden and share the joys together
and we are grateful for those who have
made it possible so far
here we can see I would want to say God
bless you God bless you
yep
am I on silent no
uh thank you thank you Charles um yeah
thanks Charles
your work is just beginning you know uh
120 000 to mobilize across West Africa
is going to be an incredible project and
I always say
you're going to have generational impact
you're gonna you're gonna impact
millions of lives
um with the single act of getting chess
sets to the community one chess that can
change the Dynamics of a whole Community
five chess sets can can lead to a chess
club and chess program in an entire
school or prison facility a refugee camp
and imagine doing that times hundreds
times hundreds times hundreds and
chestnuts don't disappear and they don't
disintegrate and they don't they don't
go bad I mean they'll live on forever
and these chestnuts will reach hands for
years to come and and the stories are
yet to be told and the impact may not be
known in um in our lifetime so
um thank you Charles
um I do have a special guest that just
joined he's coming out of um
Wichita Kansas and the United States
he's our director of prison Outreach at
the gift of Chess
um just this past year he was
um provided the opportunity to travel
the entire state of Kansas As It Gets a
chest representative he went to all
eight Statewide facilities across the
state of Kansas running USCF chess
championships at each of the facilities
Distributing chess sets sharing the
power of Chess and then it culminated in
the first ever online state
championships all the winners of each
facility played against each other on an
online state championship and do you
know that we're going to build upon it
and hopefully in the coming years we'll
make it a national championship where
every facility in the United States will
have a Chess Championship and all those
facilities will play in a state
championship and all the states will
play in a national championship and will
really use chess
um as a rehabilitation tool to change
um so many logicals and courses I like
to give the floor to my good friend um
Tony Ballard joining us from um Kansas
and I'll share about a little bit of our
work and um encourage you guys to
support us as well so thank you Tony
hi everyone I'm glad to be here with
everyone
um we're all doing great works in park
and parking on uh a great Mission a
great journey through this game called
chess that we love so much and how I can
really impact and change the lives of
everyone and
um is that Ivy over there hey ivy
hey
so yeah it's a it's a beautiful thing
that we you know speaking of Ivy you
know prime example of the impact of
Chess and how great it is and and how
super uh powerful it is I've always
spoke to my colleagues my friends about
chess and the healing powers that chess
has and so you know we're all here today
just giving a piece of ourselves and and
our time to to Really spread the word
and spread the gift of Chess to to all
um globally uh Nationwide and worldwide
right here in Kansas we've been working
with implementing chess programming in
uh Kansas department of corrections as a
cognitive Rehabilitation tool and for
those that don't know my story you know
I use chess uh during my 20 plus years
in prison just to help uh develop
thinking skills to really Challenge and
and change the way that I thought the
way that I decided made choices
because when I first came into prison I
was very impulsive you know I made a lot
of very uh costly decisions based upon
just being impulsive
um and that was fueled by drugs it was
fueled by just uh emotionally
emotionally driven
but the more and more I began to play
the game of chess the more of the game
just had me to just to slow down and
think about my moves and and being that
I'm competitive I hate to I hated to
lose and so it required me to really
be more patient with my thoughts and my
decisions and once I applied that on the
chessboard I start having great great
success and so I said to myself well
let's try this in my own life and so I
began to just be patient uh be more uh
strategic and and and just deciding and
making choices and decisions rather than
being impulsive and making those quick
choices in this decision that impact my
life and obviously it's impacted my life
that impulsive choice in
2003 impacted my life for the last 20
plus years
um but the great thing about it is that
as being experimenting my own uh being a
guinea pig in my own experiment we found
out that it works and now we're we're
pushing to get chess in these prisons
and use it as a tool to help the prison
environment a lot of guys in prison are
fighting they're making impulsive
decision because they're they're fueled
up on anger they're filled up on they're
very emotionally driven and not only
that they have a very high impact of
drugs in prison and so a lot of them are
still addicted to drugs we give them the
game a chance and it drives them away
from doing that because in prison you
get bored with with monotonous of just
you wake up you work you go to sleep you
wake up you work you go to sleep it's
the same thing in and out every day it's
the same there's nothing new and then
there's all the drama that happens
around in the prison environment that
people can get drawn into and so having
the game of chess having an activity
that can take your mind away from your
environment away from prison is an
escape in itself I play chess for hours
and hours on end during the day just to
escape what was going on in the
environment I look up
and I started playing chess at 9am this
is five o'clock P.M you know and I'm
focused on the board I'm not focused so
much on all the the bickering and the
fighting and the conflict and the the
things that's going on around me because
I'm so focused on my choices and
decision making on the board and I'm
having a blast while I'm doing it I'm
having so much fun hi Susan
and and Big Ups to Susan you know uh my
colleague my friend my sister she she's
doing great work over there uh Phyllis
being being a part of get the chance
Russell this Vision that you have you
know you brought us all together all up
under the game of chess you know we love
the game we all know the importance of
it and so we're here because of this
game but but the vision and bringing it
together as one Russell and Tyrone um
I have a family now like you guys are my
family
you know
um I love you guys because of what
you're doing I love you guys because of
your outstanding character you know the
sacrifice that you made the the trials
and tribulations that you've been
through the smiles that you see on the
children faces when we when we provide
them with these chess boards we're
making a big impact we're changing the
world and I believe that we we can we
can you know Russell you we can win
Nobel Peace Prize you know we can do
something awesome you know but you know
being in the game
um growing up Russ I was at a gang you
know a Hoover gang out of Tulsa
Oklahoma north side and when you're in a
gang you sacrifice a lot for that game
you sacrifice your family you sacrifice
your friends you sacrifice your time you
know I've spent 25 plus years in prison
as a result of being loyal to a gang you
know but when I look at the gift of
Chess and my colleagues my family is
over here we are a gang too and we're a
game that's out here changing world you
know we're doing something positive and
we in it together and and just like I
was loyal to that gang and and that that
environment that didn't mean anything to
me it wasn't loyal to me I I pledged my
allegiance and my loyalty to the gift of
Chess and I want to work with you all
and continue this effort that we're
doing
thank you Tony that was
incredible and um you've inspired so
many people all over the world
as the Director of the prison Outreach
your stories and your leadership now has
prison Outreach in so many countries I
know we're doing stuff in Nigeria in the
prisons and Malawi and uh in Kenya and
all over the world and you know the
stories that we tell have the ability to
impact the world and thank you for
leading from the front leading body
example I just want to ask um Agame to
short show a quick clip of some of the
work that Tony's done in uh in the state
of Kansas
uh sure sure
[Music]
there we go
sorry about that uh all right here we go
what is
hey Russell
I'd like to know if you can share some
of those uh letters that we get uh
appreciate uh Sean thanks and
appreciation thank you they're streaming
a video just one sec oh so just starting
off man I just most definitely want to
give thanks to our secretary correction
Jeff zamutu man I seen him at the
Wichita Work Release gave him an
elevated pitch real fast real quick told
them about the project and he signed up
and got on board with it and went and
reached out to captain on it and here I
am this is our fourth facility I've been
to Hutch Winfield El Dorado and now here
this is a a great project a great idea
uh the whole goal the whole mission
behind it is to get chess implemented in
prisons Nationwide to where we can use
chess as a cognitive Rehabilitation tool
to help us change our thinking help us
develop essential skills like problem
solving decision making critical
thinking skills all these skills and
skills that can be translated into your
life and help you to be successful so
our mission is to start here in Kansas
first like I said we've been to four
facilities we're going to several more
and to get it as a program credit I
would like to see chess in prison as a
program credit where people will
participate and they'll be able to get
time knocked off their sentence for
participating in the program we'll come
in behind them we'll get we'll come in
before it started give them some surveys
fill out the surveys them surveys
engaged with their problem solving
skills with the decision making skills
is with the critical thinking skills is
and then after the program will come
back with another survey and that survey
will highlight how how well they've been
taught how well
the chess has translated 25 minute clock
five second delay meaning once they
start
you hit it and you stop yours you start
his
he hits it he stops his he starts yours
foreign
just so happy to be able to bring the
gifted chest to those incarcerated in my
state because the whole purpose behind
being able to bring this game is for
people to develop a habit of good
decision making good problem solving and
and being able to make those choices on
the Fly make those choices in
spontaneous situations and good moments
a lot of us including myself when we got
incarcerated one thing that we did was
we made impulsive or rash decisions and
speaking for myself that has cost me 25
plus years of my life it's cost me
relationships with my family my friends
and my loved ones and now that I play
the game of chess now that I understand
how important it is to think first to re
be responsive and to make good sound
choices in the decision based off my
observation and all the information that
I've analyzed I am able to apply that to
my life and I can say now today that I
put a plan together and that plan is to
get chess into all prisons in the United
States of America to where men and women
can use this game and be a calm
effective thinkers and and listeners and
and creative skilled makers so those of
you that are out there you see what
we're doing I ask you to come alongside
us and help us Advance this initiative
I compare life to chest yeah to 64
squares on this board and I compare
everything in life to chess every move I
do in life
is off of moving off a chessboard
I just wake up every day and I strive
every second of my life
not to be put in Checkmate just make you
sit back and think about your moves
before you actually do them you know
what I'm saying chess is a thinking
man's gang and here you want to survive
this time you gotta think about your
actions
a very nice beautiful video
yeah it's really
um highlights the important work
um and uh Antonio's did a great job and
it's growing it's expanding and we've
got a lot of support from the government
now in the state of Kansas to build upon
that so that's exciting
um next next guest I'd like to invite is
our young Superstar she was featured
recently on Reuters and today she
actually was featured on the BBC she's
eight years old
um my name is Ivy and she's out of Abuja
in Nigeria she's got a big smile on her
face and she's been spending all of her
time traveling across uh her home City
and sharing the gift of Chess and she's
inspired so many people across the world
and she does an incredible job so I'd
like to see if she's around she can come
say a couple of words
[Music]
I mean you gotta unmute we see you but
you got to unmute we can't hear you
there you go
hello everyone
hi can you hear us
okay as she gets her um
I think it's a signal issue yeah so
we'll move on um next person I want to
use our ambassador and he's doing great
work across the country of uh of Zambia
we've recently uh traveled alongside of
him and he's taken to the entire country
and he's doing great work we asked
Prosper to come say a couple words about
the Outreach in Zambia
foreign
I hope you can hear me
loud and clear
my name is Sam from Zambia
we recently received 1 000 chances from
the gift of Chase that we are
Distributing in various facilities like
uh schools
um free zones orphanages
refugee camps and the messages that
we've been receiving from these
recipients are
so amazing and I'm really happy to work
with the gift of Chase as we share the
same goal of spreading
the universal language of chess
uh I am a school Chase instructor and
I've been seeing some challenges that
we've been facing in Zambia and seeing
that uh the gift of Chase is doing a
magnificent Global
um
activity of Distributing Chase rates in
different countries I also reached out
to them to request for this and um so
far I have
uh distributed uh in I would say four
provinces and we've also introduced
Chase in the libraries so that you know
we can expand the the reach of chance in
different communities you know people
can go in the libraries and access those
chances as they are free for the public
and the public are now enjoying that
they've seen uh an increase number of
people visiting the libraries
and of course they are appreciating and
loving the game in these facilities and
in the orphanages that we visited so far
there are children there who have never
even seen a chessboard before
and when you go there you show them how
the chest looks like and the pieces and
there's so much willing to learn the
game of Chase and also to benefit from
uh the game of chess because you know it
isn't just a game that is supposed to be
played for fun but okay there are so
many skills that we learn from chess
some of them we don't even know that
they're coming from chess meanwhile it's
chess that is uh teaching you so many
lessons that um uh uh well so uh more
important to individuals and I'm really
glad to
you know our partners and donors out
there that are making it possible for us
here you know it's from the people to
the people
so it's just a magnificent work that is
being put in to see change in children
and also uh you know to encourage
critical thinking and analytical skills
in schools you know it's all magnificent
there's nothing more I would ask for
except for working with the gift of
Chase
and um I would also like the people out
there to come on board and help us with
this initiative as it is
um something that is supposed to benefit
people we are seeing children that are
abusing drugs in our communities and we
are now developing some centers for
those children to stop the abuse of
drugs and be kept busy with Chase you
know and we we are yet to also excel in
doing some other programs that we are
drafting at the moment and um hopefully
I'll be able to talk about that in our
next live stream thank you so much
thank you uh Prosper for all the
incredible works that you're doing um
let's move it along I'd like to ask our
ambassador from Uganda Ronald say a
couple words about the updates of what's
going on in um in Uganda and uh maybe
some words for inspiration encouraging
people to come alongside us uh in
support
uh hey uh good evening from the pal of
Africa can you guys hear me
uh we can hear you
all right so um blessed to have you guys
on board I can see
Tony my boss Emmanuel Ross
uh blessings The Iron Lady and the whole
team is on so thank you so much
um so yeah
so uh my role is to thank you guys for
the great works you're doing and um
personally I'm going to uh because I
would love to speak of The Works we've
been doing but
I would rather the work speak for
themselves and I'll speak about what the
works have done
yeah
so the works we've done
have
transcended time
have bent norms and beliefs
they've created longer tables and
bridges so that people could have
beautiful conversations
um they've United a field in communities
because
um to be specific I'll give an example
of a
of the recent projects you've had
we've visited a school
that has 1800 kids
yeah and um in the school like education
is not much of a thing yeah due to like
to some circumstances and stuff so
cheers
Chase did something like really like
special because it's good
it was the first time
the community heads the parents the kids
and the teachers got together
in in one meeting
yeah so as to see
how best can they work together to see
how best
can this thing
change the community like how can it
impact the community yeah so we've seen
chess
take people from Zero to Hero yeah and
we've seen Chase
create outliers like that like with the
famous queen of country Fiona
so like this
has been so vital in lives of people
yeah so it has really created like a
very very good feel and like it's a
really very good tool so
that being said I'll speak on the part
where I want you guys to come and
support us yeah so I'm sure like we've
been all talking about like the support
and stuff and you're wondering Lucas so
why should we help
yeah because you've been seeing the
Oxford doing online and stuff and you're
like why should we help because
maybe you've contributed before to other
organizations and you've seen like the
same problems
over the years
yeah but when you observe when you
observe our content we are not just
posting like shabby kids from remote
communities of Africa
no
we are posting potential
we are treating potential we are
treating greatness
we are treating
like
what can be
we are treating the future
in the present
you see because in chess there's a
saying that a pawn can become a queen
but with a gift of chess what I've come
to learn in the years I've been involved
in that project is like in chess with a
gift of Chess it's not just a queen
it's the ability of a pawn to become
what it wants
because when it crosses it can become a
rook I know I can't explain that but
just committee that you know but that's
what the gift of Jesus is all about
the gift of Jesus has has detached
itself from the idea of bringing the
solution
but it's part of the solution
yeah so I know you guys have heard
before have contributed before to causes
and I don't want to stand and say this
is different
but if you take time to observe beyond
the narrative
and see the exact idea
then you landed there's a difference in
the approach
because we're not all about this
solution
we're all we're doing is
we're selling a simple concept
like you guys from wherever you are
maybe like you face your own ex you have
your own experiences with communities
and stuff
what we are saying is
you have the power to become
you have the potential to become
all you need to do is to learn how best
to maneuver and what we are doing we are
bringing like just one simple set 64
squares and 32 pieces and we're saying
okay so so you're the pawn but you can
actually become one one of the pieces on
the first or seventh rank so you just
need to know how to juggle on these six
step for squares which is which is your
your day-to-day life and then you can
learn how best to go ahead
so that's what we're doing and
we are not saying that like okay we we
we're going to teach you fast the basics
and we're going to like create a
community which is good but we realize
that okay
you might not become like a Magnus
Carlsen but
you have the skills actually
you can critically think you can analyze
you can observe and you can apply that
in your day-to-day life and we're saying
okay in there we are building a
community because with Chase whatever
like it's a community of well-educated
perspected and influential people you
are saying okay in this community we are
building in the specific countries you
can actually go
in that community and you say the moment
you say I'm a chess player
you already have a community you have a
family
yeah
so like there's no way you can fail
there's no way you can fail
because what you need first you have the
skills
like 21st century skills and you have a
community so all you need to say is hey
I'm here I'm part of the community
here's how you can help me and you
already have someone to hold your hand
so imagine you've done that in 12
countries and we're saying no we've not
even scratched surface
you want to be everywhere in Africa by
2030 and you want to introduce to spread
the gift of Chess by giving one million
chess sets
yeah so what we're saying is with five
thousand dollars
you can actually like support what I've
just talked about in a different country
so it's not a matter of taking a chess
board in a country it's a matter of
telling a story of the country
giving the power and the tools to the
community to tell its own stories so
it's bigger than a chessboard the
chessboard is just a tiny piece and just
imagine like what influence you can have
on those people by just joining on and
contributing so come be part of Us come
see potential come believe with us that
it's possible to do great things from a
small place but
therein we have to believe in humanity
to a point of action
yeah so if you're fed up of seeing like
uh little kids with mucus from remote
communities in Africa and you really
want to see how a pawn can become a king
you know you you know where where to put
your money it's on the gift of this
thank you
thank you rob that was incredible every
time that you speak I'm always
um
inspired by your words and with that
being said I've won a good friend of
mine um he's here he has to leave but
I'll say a couple words
he was one of the Lost Boys of Sudan
um if you guys have followed the story
he experienced tremendous amount of
challenges and tragedies life but he
learned a game of chess by a single
chess set in a camp in Kenya and through
that single chest that he found a new
home and a new community and he became a
United States Chess Master he's now in
the United States
um teaching chess and spreading the
gifts of Chess and his name is Major I'd
like him to say a couple words before he
has to go
all right
how is everybody can I can you guys hear
me yes hello hello major hi yes
so my name is Major Josh I'm from Sudan
which is southern Sudan right now
so
yeah I'm I've Been Working for with Russ
for
maybe seen
a long time so we were walking in one
company in New York and now
and now I'm here and uh in Maine doing
some game of chess it was a month of the
kid from Angola
so
so that's uh chess is has been great for
me as back in Africa when I was in Kenya
there was not that many chess players or
just one so we just play for fun but it
was always
so when I play chess when I'm on a
chessboard I pretty much forget
everything else that going on
um
and I just concentrate on that so
is one of the great gift and is one of
the great game so it's always
it's good for your mind and it's also
be laughing like for me right now the
chess has been
done great thing for me
so not only I like to play chess
but
it's the job that I do now in New York
so
there's big potential and a health kid
same so I want to give more of those
kids the kid I teach
I want to give them
I want to see the smile again
they do after they learn how to play
chess and after they win that first game
so it's a husband
a great game and continue to be a great
game so I'm always happy
if there is
somebody willing to learn and especially
the youngster if they are so I'm always
happy to teach
to teach us so
for us I am here I'll teach one of the
kids and first of all some of this day
I will be back in Africa and maybe I'll
teach some
I teach them each other
so
that's
so I just want to say all that and thank
for everybody who is doing a chess work
and
yeah so I'm gonna
I have I had to go so that's why thank
you thank you major for
your efforts for your story
um your inspiration and I look forward
to seeing you soon so thanks for joining
um next I'm going to ask um the the a
good friend of mine also from Nigeria
Legacy was um helping lead the chess
Muslims project and he also led the
school in makoka which is the largest
floating slum in Africa
um and he has done so much work to
advance our project and just chess as a
tool uh for the African Child So
Emmanuel thank you for joining us
hi good evening everyone
Emmanuel
uh I'm so happy to be here and um Ross
thank you for this opportunity
and I will just
um want to share
um a few kind words so
every chance evangelists cheers
evangelist on the meeting today
because we are the soldiers uh like the
missionaries
spreading the
um good works of the game of chess
um I we've made chess become a game that
has transcend 64 squares and 32 pieces
to a phenomenal object that empowers to
a phenomenal game that give Wings to
dreams to phenomenal game that
can become a support base
for children in disadvantaged background
and marginalized communities and this is
a really great work it's not been easy I
must say but sincerely
how how far we've come looking at it and
this wouldn't have been possible without
you and I and these and
um I also want to take a moment to
appreciate uh Ross for your undying
Spirits you you just
get the dream and you say this is doable
and you have this this Spirit like oh
you don't take no for an answer once
Ross just set his eyes to it he just
wants to make uh make sure it gets done
and uh thanks to everyone on this
meeting today and there is more to be
done there's more work to be done
um for the countries that have received
um we are still hopeful that Ghana is
coming through then Nigeria will get a
lot of people are
expectations are high so people are
waiting just to hit the ground running
and we hope to do more and we call for
support because the game of chess has
helped we have seen it
um on every site because we work with
Street children
children from disadvantaged backgrounds
and we've seen what they have become
with the game of chess
um the national chairs opening will be
starting soon and a lot of kids from our
slums who would never have thought about
leaving their communities living their
tiny communities different states have
reached out to us such as in slums that
they want us to give them kids they want
them to give us to give them chess
players to join
to come and represent the various States
and we have that numbers coming in and
it's it's a thing of Joy seeing a child
that's some some of these kids never
thought they could ever have gotten the
chance to board the plane to go and
represent a state but with the game of
chess that dream is coming alive now and
that is just the beginning for them and
um thank you so much and for you can
support this Mission you can be part of
this Mission and I know so much has been
said I just want to say
um thank you to everyone once again and
Ross thank you for the opportunity yeah
thank you manual yeah you're welcome
thank you uh if everybody's joining I
know we're getting to the end I still
have a couple more of people I'd like to
um give a chance to speak to and we have
um Kenneth who's representing uh
Tanzania very quickly if you want to
just talk about some of the impact that
chess has had um Kenneth in your
community
um
uh good evening everyone uh hello
everyone it's already evening here in
Tanzania uh
it's been a roller coaster and uh
to see that uh chess is running down in
uh in Tanzania it's it's really uh
previously when I when we started just
in Tanzania it was like chess is a
gambling game this is a game that people
think their kids are going to start
gambling their kids are going to think
about money uh like the way they use
other other games uh they totally people
that I didn't know about the game of
chess but then um
uh we started with uh ourselves uh
teaching the kids trying to get uh
and try to get um
um schools take up chest and then
apparently in the previous
um
two years has been on ground with a
little logistic equipment and access to
schools and and centers uh so far we
have a success story of one of the
volunteers of the gift of Chess in
Tanzania he's gotten a scholarship to go
to a Poland University
to study just because he's a chess
player and then he's also the highly
rated youth player in Tanzania so a
clubhouse Charles is one of the story
he's uh we are putting up a documentary
for that and uh I think he's a he's an
example he's a is the model to most of
the kids that are learning just right
now he's in uh he's in iringa where he
took chessboards to Don Bosco's Coast
um uh on um on on Thursday and uh he had
session through uh yesterday today and
then uh tomorrow as well so we are going
to have a cover of that and uh we are
going to send through uh I think we are
going to share most of these things in
the world I think uh it's burning as we
started just here we say chess is the
future and indeed we are we are pulling
off that and this is the future we call
upon everyone that can come and stand in
and and give a high five to uh to
today world
thank you thank you Kennedy uh we've
been following your works we support you
we appreciate your efforts and keep up
the great job and for those that are
listening
um please consider supporting our our
Outreach it takes a commercial amount of
uh support from volunteers and just
Blood Sweat and Tears to get these chess
outside of the community but it also
takes the resources to make that
possible so if you're listening and you
could come alongside of us
um we need about five thousand dollars
to reach a new country
um we have 50 000 chestnuts in Africa we
want to mobilize across each country in
Africa within the next six months and um
your support will help help make that
possible on the next guest I'd like to
ask to speak is um one of the Champions
she's actually a great example of the
power of Chess she's
um from Kenya her name is Bernice wambu
she's the current national champion and
um I believe she's 12 years old if she's
here hopefully she can say a couple of
words and I think I did see her is she's
still here if she's not then I'm going
to move
um for
um evil is your connection better do you
have a chance to say a couple of awards
yes
is 16 years
[Music]
is better
much better much better
Olivia tell us
um why why chess is so important and
maybe why it's important for uh people
to support the gift of Chess and
continue our great work
um
it's very fun giving up spreading out
the gift of just people so that they can
learn how to play chess
and we teach them
the game of chess so that they can learn
how to play chess and be a better person
when they grow up
that's wonderful thank you so much we
saw you on the BBC today and Reuters
were following your work you're
inspiring people all over the world
you're only eight but I think if people
can realize it's possible to do great
things from a small place but it's also
possible to do great things when you're
a small person you know your smallest
smaller than anybody else and you're
only a child but you're having
incredible impact that's very
inspirational to us sometimes you know
the adults in the room and uh we've all
work together and it's someone that's
eight could have such a big impact we
should all be inspired by that so keep
up
um the great job
um I think pernicious Bernice could you
say a couple of words about the working
Kenyon we just like to hear from you
um the work we do in Kenya we
distributes I suppose to people in
disadvantaged community
if you have you feel like our own
feeling in your heart when you help them
because when you see the happy faces
that are getting to know chess because
usually train them it's when you go to
slams they usually have drugs there it
took them away from drugs so it keeps
them occupied
now produce do you want to share I I I
hear you're representing your country in
competitions can you share a little bit
about what your chess career happening
in a chess career now
yes
um on Thursday evening I'm going to
Netherlands for the world under 16
Olympiad and I'll be representing Kenya
we're rooting for you and we're all very
proud of you British keep up the great
job thank you
um I'd like to ask one of the founding
board members he actually was the first
member from the gifted chest to travel
to Africa and to connect with the team
from Nigeria including
um Tunica and Emmanuel and Tyrone Davis
who's now working on Wall Street and
um advancing his career um he's here I
think he's playing but if you can say a
couple words
um Tyrone if you're here
yes I'm here can you hear me
we can hear you
can you see me yeah yeah
uh wow I mean I've been you're actually
here listening to the entire stream and
playing a bit and it's just fantastic I
you know Russ and I
we were the first movers you can say in
this entire all right Adventure
yeah and to see us go from oh sorry is
there a I think there may be an echo
uh let me just turn this off
okay turn that off
um to see us go from
Distributing
well one raising money to to buy 10 000
chess sets in New York City and
distributing those chess sets around New
York City to Distributing chess sets
across the world
I mean I don't think Russ and I could
have ever imagined having such reach
impact so far beyond New York City
um I've known Russ since I was probably
11 years old
and Russ and I consider we're family now
but after probably a year and a half of
working with everyone on this call and
everyone you've you've heard speak I
consider everybody you've heard family
to this point I I do plan on going back
to Africa this summer
uh to rekindle relationships past and
and new relationships with new partners
and
to further Inspire I've become much
I remember when I was a competitive
player Russell remembers when I would
play in tournaments Bernice is going
through that phase now of playing
competitions day in and day out that
once was me now I've become so much more
Joyful from inspiring others to play
chess not me playing chess myself it's a
weird transition as a former competitive
player to becoming more of a uh I don't
know what you call somebody who inspires
but someone who just enjoys inspiring
people to play and sharing opportunity
uh I work on Wall Street now in New York
City and I attribute a lot of
my journey to Wall Street now from the
relationships I've developed through
chess
uh so trust gave me a lot trust gave me
confidence to sit across anybody
and to believe that I can win that the
work that I put in at home reading books
watching you know videos like yours
agamater
um all the
yeah books puzzles tactics all that work
I put in that trust allowed me to be
confident in my hard work and and say
that okay now it's me and you against
each other and hopefully
the best player who put in the most work
wins and that's how you know life
should kind of be you put in hard work
and you and you see that Hardware come
out in some successful results so to
teach kids in Africa in New York City
and California
um you know we've even set chest sets to
Ukraine to teach kids all around the
world that you put in hard work you can
be confident in yourself and potentially
see you know a successful result is a
great lesson to teach and so so excited
every day to do that hopefully you guys
can join us and
contribute and you know join in on this
journey it's only beginning so
thank you for having me speak anything
else Russ
how did you do today how many points did
you get in the arena I actually did very
I did I'm proud of how I how I played
I'm not a
uh let's see I have
46 points and only loss like what places
that I know there's like 2 500 players
is that 100 213th place as of now so
you're proud of being in the top 200.
okay that's good
in this tournament that's a great
success
um actually one
because I know that Tony Ballard had uh
something he wanted to say before if
he's still here
um Tony if you are here
um please consider oh please I know you
want to share a letter and an appeal so
um please feel free to oh you guys never
say so Tony this uh
yeah I just wanted to say uh you know
that's what chess can do for you you can
take you places you know what I mean
it could take you places
um uh co-founder and friend uh Tyrone
you know MIT grad man that's that's
what's up and you know Bernice and and
Ivy just the the young young kids coming
up in the game of chess and doing great
things They're Gonna Go Far let's keep
track of their story and their success
but I just wanted to thank you
aggravator
because
these guys in prison are watching these
videos and they're learning it so much
about the game with chess they're
becoming inspired that there's a deeper
aspect to the game of chess you know
there's there's just so much more at the
chest than just you know the 64 squares
and the 32 pieces it's it's you know the
openings the middle game the end games
the the royal blue pass the London
system you know uh the Scandinavian you
know there's so much that these these
guys in prison didn't even know nothing
about but you you breaking down these
game for them and introducing it to them
in prison has just broadened their
Horizons opened their minds to to the
deeper games of Chess and and they've
been writing so many letters you know
aggravator just thanking you and and
thanking to get the chance for for what
we've offered them and and I just wanted
to take the opportunity to just again to
say thank you we really appreciate you
the impact is huge and and there's also
letters that uh if Russell has time that
he can maybe read one of them to you but
yeah thanks
my pleasure uh have they gotten any
better since starting the videos
hey so there's actually a Phenom there's
a total Phenom uh uh agamater in prison
this guy he has a photographic memory uh
he just wrote to us out the blue uh
Russell you remember that you remember
the letter about this guy yeah he said
he said it is but he remembers every
game that's ever been played you know
something something like that you know
it's really been uh pretty tremendous
but I I will be able to I could I can
surely um read a letter
um and I can do that now um I'll pull
one up that talks about the impact of um
of Chess
um and it's a letter that we received so
um let me just get it here
um so it goes like this
um here get the chance I wanted to thank
you
everyone involved with the gift of Chess
in adova I spend countless hours in deep
stimulation and amusement through the
Adobe application the greatest gift is
freedom for those times I'm watching
listening to the host aggrimator analyze
all the games I'm free
for matches of Ian and ding are
wonderful and the newest mirror and
series are great I still don't know who
won the Chess Championship Series
between Ian and ding but I watch the
matches every day I play chess when I
can which isn't enough for my craving I
live in solitary confinement by myself
for years now but once in a while I have
a chance to play with other people and
enjoy playing very much there's a player
who has a photographic memory a friend
of mine the score he has 167 wins for
him and 12 for me I've tested his mind
and I am blown away by him both as a
player and friend
you can't remember every game ever
played and it's unbelievable thank you
to the gift of chess team thank you to
Tony Ballard and thank you to aggravator
well that's that's pretty incredible
yeah it really is when
you look at the prison environment and
you think that there's nothing but
garbage there's trash there but in the
midst of all of that there's there's
Treasures there's people who've made
some some terrible mistakes we're not
excusing that but there's also Beautiful
Minds there that can be cultivated that
can be led in the right direction and if
given a channel given the Avenue you
know they can they can become something
great and and it's all starts with the
mind and chess is the key for that and
man I'm just blown away by the day and
everybody that's participating man I'm
I'm just stoked man thanks a lot man
thanks Tony so uh I'll hand it back to
you I don't know how we want to
um if the if the arena is over if you
want to announce the winners and the
prizes
um but I do encourage those are
listening
um please uh contribute either now or in
the future five thousand dollars helps
us reach an entire new country with 1
000 chess sets there are a lack of chess
sets globally and if one thing that you
heard from people today is chess is a
low-cost tool that can change lives if
you believe in education you believe in
Opportunity you believe in
Rehabilitation you love the game of
chess we're asking you humbly to support
us we are not a wealthy organization
this is an organization that's been
driven by Blood Sweat and Tears and for
us to continue we need to support
um big or small to come alongside us we
believe in it and we need other people
to come alongside us and support us so
thank you Akinator for your platform and
uh your friendship thank you to
everybody that joined us today thank you
all the team here and the good work is
just beginning and we gotta keep on
plugging away and the good days and bad
days and when you believe in something
you believe the value of your own ideas
you need to find a way to make some they
had enough you can keep it going and
keep it moving forward so
um aggravated thanks again I'll hand it
off to you to um for any final
announcements and um we consider and
talk for for the for the rest of the day
but I know the event was planned from uh
you know from one to three to 1900 to
2100 so I'll I'll hand it back to you uh
well firstly I just want to congratulate
the winners um uh Andrew Tang wanted to
still under the name GM uh penguin I am
as he I think he made the handle when he
was still an international Master even
though he's a grand master now so big
congratulations to him as second place
illuminate tops I don't know who that is
I can check if it says here but no
uh but yeah since May
2023 so not not the new account but not
not an old one
in third place so those are the three
big Winners and since we have prizes uh
going from uh third to Tenth uh Freedom
Master Rob from Armenia in fourth place
Eddie kelman 19-3 uh in fifth place we
have um uh this is uh Matthew Matthew G
at p4p from Russia uh also International
master in sixth place Chicago Sergey uh
the top seed of the tournament got a
seventh place or rather he was top seed
when the tournament started but I think
uh yeah okay but he's somewhere in there
with with Andrew uh then we have Joseph
2013 in eighth place uh Tamo Jerry ninth
and The Grandmaster Jester uh okay we
can also check who that is as I do not
know
uh yep also playing anonymously so we're
gonna contact all of them thank you guys
for playing and we will uh we will
continue regarding the the distribution
of prizes now uh regarding uh regarding
the charity event uh thank you Russ for
organizing such a magnificent event
you've uh organized so many people to
get together I mean over over the course
of basically an hour and a half and uh
you've rushed them you were really like
uh like a people's Master re or
organized it well and uh okay we we
didn't hit our goal uh but you know we
we did achieve something let me see how
we've done all right so okay I have to
update it a little bit about a few
dollars short of two thousand dollars
which is
I think around what we we did for the
previous one but I will upload this
video separately and I will maybe even
try to try to make smaller ones which
are more easily easily digestible to
people uh we live in a different world
nowadays you know times are faster and
uh sometimes people just don't have two
hours to to listen to what someone is
doing but I think we can uh we can do a
little bit better or you know through
uh through reaching people with maybe uh
bits of content and maybe not uh not
another two-hour one but yeah I'm happy
with with how we've done I'm pretty sure
we can do better in the future uh you
know it's important to to strive
yeah I think you know any uh anybody
that heard tonight that or today that
didn't hasn't heard prior about the get
the chess project is a huge win and um
sometimes the baby steps when you
aggregate them like like little small
good chess moves over the course of a
game you sometimes get a Checkmate so I
think this has been a huge success and
just being able to connect with um
everyone on this call on you and I know
people out there heard us about us for
the first time and that's the most
important thing is just just uh getting
the opportunity to speak to new people
and let make make them aware of the
great works and the importance that
chess has on uh being a tool for
opportunity
um across the globe so thank you so much
yeah and we've I mean I've really
enjoyed all of the all of the guests
they had some incredible stories from
incredible places I think we had maybe
even twice as many guests as on the
previous stream uh maybe on the next one
we can have uh we could have like maybe
30 or 40 guests maybe we can commit once
a year we'll do uh we'll do a stream if
that's okay and we'll we'll bring more
and more people as we grow
yeah what's uh Africa like 54 countries
right we could have one from every
country right right
yeah okay that's a goal for for 2030
right
well the goal for 20 30 is every country
in the entire world we'll finish Africa
in every country in the world okay yeah
so I don't know how many countries that
is exactly but we'll finish all of
Africa in the next six months every
country in Africa will have a thousand
chess sets so
you are confident you will be able to
well I mean we have the sets in Africa
all we need to do is just hit hit go and
um
working it done so it will it will
happen in good time I'm confident
all right uh well Russell thank you for
everything I've had I've had a great
time I've enjoyed uh seeing some of them
again meeting meeting new people uh I I
mean I I love it the world you guys are
doing on all fronts uh both with the
with the gift of Chess in uh
Distributing the chesses but also with
the prison program I think it's
outstanding and uh not I mean that's
what prisons are for they're not there
to punish people they're they're the
rehabilitate people and bring them back
into society and
I don't know uh uh without chess I mean
you have you you need something like
chess chess or programming or something
they can
uh connect to but I think it's the the
easiest to achieve with chess
so I think it's a it's a a beautiful
initiative
uh all right so that's it uh thank you
everyone for for joining in uh thank you
uh all of the guests and uh until next
time uh we're gonna discuss how to move
forward and uh hopefully you guys will
be able to contribute uh a bit more we I
was hoping to reach at least one country
in this stream uh but maybe after after
a few days uh you know we will get more
contributions
very good
all right bye-bye until next time and
thank you everyone for for joining the
stream and once again big
congratulations to everyone who
participated in the tournament and to
the winners of the tournament uh in the
end we had over 3 000 people 3 809
people in the tournament uh yeah very
nice uh until next time
thank you thank you